des images de cartes postales qui font
normalement courir des amateurs d'ego
portrait mais aux quatre coins du pays
ces monuments célèbres restent déserts
en gaspésie seul le soleil vient visiter
le rocher percé au lieu de préparer ses
croisières 7 batelière et forcés
d'attendre des touristes qui peut-être
ne viendront pas ça va être très dur ça
va être très dur ça va être une saison à
oublier pour son entreprise familiale de
père en fille chaque saison compte ça
serait ce journalier devoir percer qui
est pratiquement une ville fantôme on
souhaite que ça va vivre qu'on puisse
mettre la main à la pâte est allé
chercher une part du marché pour les
restaurateurs qui affronte la tempête de
l'aco vide
le constat est le même jeu juillet ou
septembre ça représente la moitié du
chiffre d'affaires annuel
forcé de mettre à pied une trentaine
d'employés ils appréhendent la saison
estivale six mois ça diminue de 5 ans
pour ça mais ça va diminuer de 50%
autant pour celui qui me gêne saumon
fumé lui qui me mit produits de
nettoyage donc ça aura un impact global
sur tout le monde
un effet régional qui s'étend à
l'ensemble du pays avec des conséquences
désastreuses destination canada estime
que dans le meilleur des cas
l'industrie du tourisme au pays perdre à
27 milliards de dollars et 194 milles
emplois et dans le pire des scénarios
c'est 48 milliards de dollars et 337
milles emplois qui disparaîtront pour
aider durant l'été ottawa a ouvert une
petite porte on va prolonger la
subvention salariale d'urgence après le
mois de juin
selon nos informations la subvention
salariale sera prolongé jusqu'en
septembre
l'aide est la bienvenue mais elle sera
insuffisante aux yeux de l'industrie
touristique dans les 12 prochains mois
celle qui aura la période critique pour
notre industrie le deuxième élément
c'est d'être capable aussi d'inclure les
employés saisonniers dans
l'admissibilité surtout souligner les
entrepreneurs que la subvention
salariale ne fera pas voyager les
touristes on entrevoit l'été
présentement
un difficilement destination canada
estime que l'industrie touristique
auraient besoin de 15 milliards de
dollars cet été pour survivre les gens
d'affaires et les régions qui en
dépendent espère toujours une aide
ciblée spécifiques à leurs besoins de la
part des gouvernements
une aide qui comme les touristes
continuent de se faire attendre ici
christian noël radio canada ottawa